so this film how do you even go about
expressing it obviously doppelgangers is
a main theme also the enemy within and
kind of when you're neglected is kind of
how I read it how would you describe I
would describe the movie you know at its
core it's about a family trying to move
their lives forward it's a family trying
to you know get reconnected by
disconnecting you know getting off
social media and really spending time
together and they encounter this
horrific experience of meeting
doppelgangers but around that is the
story of you know power like cultures of
power and privilege and essentially the
people that you render invisible or
speechless
the people who bear the burden of your
actions and are aware of you but you're
not aware of them because of your
privilege and you know the connection to
structures like the American Dream that
is really connected to privilege and
essentially if you attach yourself to
these constructs you then become
responsible for their lineage for you
know the cost of what it takes and are
you prepared for that to look like you
the American Dream kind of dies in it as
well as also death that's a lot of death
I think this was really powerful Phil
Jordan Peele has a really beautiful
ability of asking what other things
other than blackness other than actual
people can be the first casualties to
that genre because one of the reasons I
never was that attached to horror was
that black people were the first
casualties they're always like the first
sacrifices to the genre to make it moved
forward and now he's saying could that
be racism could that be you know the
American Dream or these these structures
you know these constructs these ideas
and how do they become the things that
are you know the casualty for the film
for
to move forward you know what else yeah
yeah you mentioned Jordan Peele there I
mean he's a master isn't he fuses this
horror and comedy somehow both funny and
very horrific in places your character
is particularly funny a lot of the funny
lines is that what kind of attracted you
to it yeah I you know I wanted something
that would kind of show a lot of range
and show something different than what
people might have seen of me before
which is like this big strong guy mbaku
and black panther but you know now
they're seeing this guy with a dead body
no I was just trying to have a good time
all the time and is totally privileged
and comfortable but also in doing all of
that you get to interrogate so many cool
social elements you know like you know
it really helps us say like in in
moments of extremity you really get to
see what doesn't serve you the isms
don't work for you you know the
patriarchy doesn't work for you when you
need to be an ally to like survive you
know and you can't be racist in the
zombie apocalypse you don't I mean so
that's really there's a lot of
commentary in everything that's around
it but you know playing these characters
fully and really leaning into the
functions of them really allow that to
come through while it's still just being
a story about a family you mentioned
Lupita there of course black panther you
guys were reunited mm-hmm yeah very
different to that universe the Marvel
Universe uh uh you know I thought it
would be so much different but it was a
lot more similar than I expected I
thought that it would be different
because they're so big in so many ways
but we ended up having to do a lot of
big work oh it's something that felt
really intimate where do two characters
and the time that you know you would
expect to do one we had to create entire
worlds
you know so what Conda was a world but
also you know this is an entire world
unto itself where we had to really
create the rules around that and what
happened
you know the doppelgangers and where
they live and all these things so it was
actually a lot more similar than I ever
expected